i think the first one i want to ask
about is working with
daniel craig on othello actually that
was daniel craig
and rachel brosnahan right yeah yeah
yeah yeah
and david david i just spoke to david
and he is wonderful and he just did his
uh feature directorial debut
so many good things for all of you right
now and he's like
father of four or five how many because
he got he got a gold gang of kids
um no david is actually a good example
of just like
we gotta keep it moving you know and
weirdly i think
having a family helps with that a little
bit you just can't dwell on
yourself too much when you've got other
people you're really having to think
about all the time
um but okay so daniel
right uh he's lovely
it was that whole experience i mean i
just you know i just shot a film with
rachel
the whole experience was just remarkable
in so many ways
a lot of it being that we were off
broadway so it wasn't this huge show
um it was huge in terms of who was in it
like you know
double 07 is in your play you're going
to get sold out before you even
the minute we announced we were sold out
sounds better it was huge in
like that but we were in this tiny
theater new york theater workshop
downtown
when i say tiny i mean probably as big
as
a large studio apartment we were all in
one dressing room they just had a
curtain between the boys and the girls
there were three girls and maybe 10 boys
so my little desk was next to
david's desk but we had a curtain
between us
right here and but i literally could
like reach over and like grab all his
makeup and steal all your [ __ ]
um can i say [ __ ] um yes you can
we'll edit oh okay great like you know
like we were
arm's length i mean i could i don't even
think i could reach my arm out
and not touch rachel like i could
probably go like this
and i would have touched rachel and she
would go like this and touch nikki like
we were right next to each other so it
was a little bit like doing theater in
college
um and you know no frills
nobody's bringing us lunch or dinner
gotta go out and get your own stuff
and daniel what was wonderful about him
first of all my audition with him
i don't know why but i went in
and i've done a bunch of you know
shakespeare and i was pretty confident
with my shakespeare stuff
but and i don't know if he did this on
purpose i should ask him at some point
he seemed so nervous
that i ended up being not nervous
does that make sense it does it was like
sweating i think that even one at one
point i even said
he started speaking we started doing
this thing he started speaking and he
was speaking so low that i was like
what what are you saying i can't hear
you i was like are you nervous you need
to speak up or something
and and i found out later on jack was
impressed by the fact that i wasn't
intimidated by daniel and i was like
yelling at him right away
to speak up so
it doesn't surprise me that him being
nervous made you less nervous
but it does make me really and this is
probably just because i'm so used to
seeing him as super competent james bond
right now it does really surprise me
that he was nervous at all
he was he was sweating i mean maybe he
was trying to make me feel less nervous
but can he manufacture sweat i don't
know
he was really maybe was the shakespeare
thing like who knows
all i know is i went in there and what i
saw was somebody who was like a deer
caught in headlights a little bit a
little panicky
and i was like try i immediately tried
to sort of make him laugh
um by yelling at him and then we had
like the best
audition um so we went from like this
you know
very big audition and then sam gold
wanted us to do it
as very intimate he was like you know
pretend like you're
in the in a movie and you're just
talking to each other right here don't
make it theatrically big but make it
like movie big
and we ended up doing this really
emotional crazy scene like
right up on each other and that there
you go
the rest is history but he's lovely he
was just
it's just fun to be around he'd be
backstage playing his guitar and
none of that big you know confident as
you say
james bond personality at all unless
except for when he was on stage and he
had to be iago